Justin here with a gamespot news update  developer criterion games has confirmed  that burnout paradise will be playable  on xbox one through backwards  compatibility the uk-based dev made the  announcement on Twitter and in exchange  with a fan but said players will need to  stay tuned for an official release date  this news isn't altogether surprising as  criterion said in july that it was  working with microsoft to add the game  to the xbox one's backward compatibility  lineup backwards compatibility for xbox  360 games is currently available on xbox  one for a preview program members only  however it won't be long until the  feature is rolled out for everyone with  an update that is set to arrive in  November Microsoft has announced that  over 100 games will be supported through  backwards compatibility but more being  added over time to find out which games  those are going to be stay tuned to  gamespot com